a Donald Trump is stepping up the
threats of tyranny by touting on Twitter
the quote absolute right to pardon
himself and yesterday I told you about
this completely tyrannical letter that
Donald Trump's attorney sent to Robert
Muller basically claiming that no matter
what Trump does you can't touch the guy
and their interpretation is that whether
the president exchanges cash for pardons
or obstructs justice or even according
to his lawyer Rudy Giuliani shoots
former FBI director James Comey dead in
the Oval Office that the law cannot
touch him unless he is impeached now
many legal scholars disagree with that
and I also pointed out yesterday that
for decades the right has been fear
mongering around tyranny whether it's
meeting guns to protect ourselves from a
tyrannical government or political
correctness being a form of tyranny but
that actually handguns won't really help
us stop the threat of tyranny that we're
facing which in this case is absolutely
belligerent claims of absolute
presidential power up to and including
the murder of American citizens we
discussed all of that yesterday ok today
I want to focus on what Donald Trump
said on Twitter which is about pardoning
himself and it's another step in the
direction of tyranny Donald Trump said
on Twitter yesterday quote as has been
stated by numerous legal scholars I have
the absolute right to pardon myself but
why would I do that when I have done
nothing wrong
in the meantime the never-ending witch
hunt led by 13 very angry and conflicted
Democrats and others continues into the
midterms and here's Trump's latest
lawyer Rudy Giuliani saying yeah the
president could pardon himself but don't
worry he has no plan to do that letter
also cites the president's pardon power
do you and the president's attorneys
believe the president has the power to
pardon himself he thought he's not but
he probably does he has no intention of
pardoning himself but he probably does
they can't I mean that is another really
interesting constitutional argument can
the president pardon himself run the
pardon attorney it would be an open
question I think it would probably get
answered by gosh that's what the
Constitution says and if you want to
change it change it but yeah a lot of
focus on the president I think the
political ramifications of that would be
tough
finding other people is one thing
pardoning yourself is another of the
presidents have pardoned people in
circumstances like this both both in
their administration and sometimes the
next president even if a different party
will come on and pardon a lot of focus
right so to be clear no president has
ever pardoned themself there does exist
a memo from the Justice Department in
1974 which was written days before
Richard Nixon resigned and it says that
the President cannot pardoned himself
because quote no one may be a judge in
his own case but let's play it to its
endpoint right if Trump pardoned himself
hypothetically it would immediately
trigger a court challenge which would be
appealed to the nation's top court the
Supreme Court which would very likely
hear the case and this means that the
decision as to whether Donald Trump
could pardon himself might come down to
Neal Gorsuch the guy that Donald Trump
put on the Supreme Court and this is why
elections matter this is why when some
on the Left say Hillary Trump whatever
it's all the same right it's not because
now Neal Gorsuch is on the Supreme Court
for life and if and when this comes up
Trump has what will very likely be a
friendly vote on that Supreme Court this
is a sort of Richard Nixon moment right
it's an if the President does it it's
not illegal it's another flavor of that
didn't work out super well for Richard
Nixon but it is a strategy and the Nick
that the Nixon difference in my view is
that there was no fox news at the time
there was no propaganda news
echo-chamber
defending Nixon no matter what he did at
the time and making him out to be the
victim in the entire Watergate scandal
and that could actually be a difference
maker in the end and what's missing from
this conversation is that it's absurd
that there's this much discussion about
a President of the United States talking
about pardoning themselves and forcing
the investigation into possible
wrongdoing by him to be closed
that's not normal normally presidents
don't regularly over a period of many
months talk about pardoning themselves
or other people and the goal posts have
been hugely moved here yeah and one
would hope that if Trump did decide to
pardoned himself and probably for some
serious crimes he would get impeached by
Congress before the course would be able
to decide on whether or not that's legal
although given that we currently have a
Republican Congress and who knows
what'll happen in the next midterms
maybe that wouldn't happen
well the timing of that is confusing
because if it's crimes related to his
duties as president he actually can't be
charged it's almost impossible to charge
them and certainly impeachment would
have to happen first if we're talking
about a criminal crime if something
unrelated to being president like
murdering James Comey for example then
it according to legal scholars you would
not first have to impeach me but even I
mean we're a jury though the medical
president can be indicted yeah yeah
number of open questions and the big
picture is that the goalposts have moved
really big Lee in the last 18 months
right it was there's nothing to look
into because no one did anything to we
did some stuff but it was all legal too
we may have done some illegal stuff but
the investigation is a witch-hunt based
on illegal leaks too even if I did it
you can't convict me anyway to I'm the
president and because I'm the president
- even if you did convict me I would
pardon myself and nearly 40 percent of
the country is watching this shameful
disaster and still supports the guy
that's really when we're talking about
indictments the biggest indictment is on
the American people that continue to say
yes I approve of the job that the
President of the United States is doing
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad